and finally new rule now that we know
that the least godly man in the world is
immensely popular with evangelicals we
need no more evidence that religion is
antiquated and dangerous this October
3rd I can't believe it is the 10th
anniversary of when my movie Religulous
opened in theaters in 2008 that is the
theaters that would show it many would
not we've come a long way back then only
16% of Americans identified as
non-religious now it's 26 percent you're
welcome
yes the fastest-growing religion in
America is no religion at all atheism is
booming praise Jesus now I learned
making Religulous that every time you
blame religion for so much of the
world's misery religious people say but
Bill the godless cultures like Hitler's
Germany in Stalin's Russia and Mao's
China were the worst and they had no
religion but here's the thing about
Nazism maoism and Stalinism those were
religions state religions these
dictators didn't get rid of God because
they hated religion they get rid of God
because they hated competition
[Music]
same with North Korea today they claim
to be godless communists but their
calendar begins on the day the country's
founder Kim il-sung came to earth from
heaven and his son the next ruler Kim
Jong Il is believed by North Koreans to
have started walking at three weeks old
and talking at eight weeks his first
time golfing he shot a thirty eight
under par with eleven holes in one
he wrote fifteen hundred books in three
years narrowly beating out Stephen King
when he was born
winter turned to spring he can make it
rain based on his mood he invented the
hamburger I'm not making that up they're
making that up he invented the hamburger
talk about a whopper oh and my favorite
Kim jong-il never used a toilet because
his body was so well calibrated he did
not need to defecate no [ __ ]
okay this is not an atheist nation I've
heard of people claim their [ __ ] don't
stink
but only a God will say they don't [ __ ]
at all which brings us to Trump
supporters the reason Trump has an easy
sell with evangelicals is because
they're hardwired to put faith over
reason plus Trump is the spitting image
of the religious con men they grew up
with on TV he's got Jim Baker's hair and
Tammy phase makeup
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's immune to sex scandal he had a sham
University he doesn't pay taxes he
personifies that prosperity gospel
[ __ ] they all spin yes the more
money I have the happier you are that's
drunk the private planes the traveling
salvation show the home that looks like
the Sistine Chapel including a crying
statue Melania
[Applause]
and it's very possible Trump doesn't
it's possible Trump doesn't just remind
his flock of their favorite preacher
there is a character in the Bible who is
exactly like Trump god no no not that
one yes now the Old Testament God Trump
loves an eye for an eye
guess it would bet the bet Old Testament
God was all wrath and ego a petty
vindictive rageaholic who loved Israel
but obsessed with loyalty not morality
look at the Ten Commandments it's very
trumpian the first four are all about
him
commandment one thou shalt have no other
gods are the gods of faith news I am the
greatest God in history with the best
brain commandment to only make statues
of me I am the only bronze colored thing
you should bow to you and don't make the
hand small cuz they're not new there was
something else I guarantee command with
three when you say bad things about me
it's very unfair very unfair know that
God has accomplished what I did in six
days that I will tell you
commandant four you must spend one day a
week not doing anything but talking
about how great I am let me help you out
God deserves an A+ so here we have the
10 commandments the 10 worst things you
could possibly do and left off the list
are torture rape child abuse incest and
slavery but four spots on the list go to
variations of stroke my ego and kiss my
ass there's only two people I can think
of who would do that God and Donald drop